All of a sudden,
all over Europe
it seems like they're everywhere:
Cargo bikes.
Delivering mail in Germany...
Amazon packages in the UK.
Picking up food waste in Paris.
And sperm donations in Copenhagen.
Yep. That's a custom built
liquid nitrogen tank shaped like
a human sperm.
In the US
whether you order a giant flat screen TV
or a week's worth of groceries...
it's likely to show up at your doorstep
via one of these:
A delivery truck or van with
a big, powerful engine.
They get the job done,
but they also emit
lots of carbon, take up
lots of room
and kill and injure
lots of people.
And that's why
cities and companies around the world
are starting to replace
some of those big vans with
electric assist cargo bikes.
But in the US, aside from test runs
from a couple of companies like
Domino's Pizza
and small pilot projects
in a handful of cities
they haven't really caught on.
So why not?
Why are we in the US
so wedded to this one tool
for delivery?
And is it possible to change course?
Even before the pandemic
online shopping was already growing
as a share of total retail sales worldwide.
And for many of us...
the pandemic habit hasn't faded away.
Even as stores have reopened.
Take London, for example.
Commercial vehicles account for about
19% of the overall miles
driven in London.
But they emit 30% of the city's
transport-related CO2.
That disproportionate impact
extends beyond pollution.
They deliver everywhere from
narrow one-way streets
to super busy intersections causing
massive traffic problems.
And between 2018 and 2020...
delivery trucks in London were involved
in a shocking 41%
of fatal cyclist crashes and
19% of pedestrian deaths.
A 2016 study found that
large trucks
made up only 3.6% of vehicles
in New York City
but are responsible for 32%
of bicyclist fatalities
and 12% of pedestrian fatalities.
So let's back up and take a bird's eye view
of the whole delivery process.
You can breakdown urban delivery into two phases.
Phase one: My iPhone cover might travel
from factory to a hub...
before the long freight journey
via airplane, cargo ship
or long haul truck to a warehouse
just outside the city where I live.
That's when phase two starts.
It's often called the last mile.
Though, the journey is usually
much longer.
That's when my package is loaded onto
a delivery truck or van
which drives into the city
and eventually stops in front of my house.
This package might have traveled
hundreds of miles to get here,
but depending on where you live
this second phase accounts for
30 to 50% of its carbon footprint.
And that's partly because the so-called
last mile is really in efficient.
One study in London found that
only a small share of vans
use more than 3/4 of their capacity.
Most use less than half.
And that's where e-bikes come in.
Obviously, using bicycles to move goods
and people through the city
is not a new idea.
UPS actually got its start
as a bike delivery service in Seattle...
hauling everything from beer
and medicine across the city.
Before city leaders remade the streets
to prioritize private automobiles
cargo bikes and trikes like these
shared the road with carriages
and pedestrians.
Today's cargo bikes can come equipped
with a small electric motor
that's activated when the pedals are in motion...
and powered by a rechargeable
lithium-ion battery.
That extra power is what allows
electric cargo bikes
like these ones in London
to outcompete delivery vans.
In a 2021 study that compared
those cargo bikes to delivery vans...
the bikes obviously had to make
more trips back and forth
to the pickup point...
but they still traveled roughly the same distance
in less time than the vans.
In part because they could park anywhere
and use the bike lanes
when the van sat in traffic.
They dropped off more packages
than the vans per hour
while emitting a fraction of the carbon.
Another study estimated that
more than half of all urban trips
related to the transport of goods
could be done by cargo bike.
Those efficiencies have led to massive
investments in Europe and the UK.
Thousands of bikes from companies
like DHL, UPS and FedEx...
as well as retailers like Amazon and IKEA.
But in the US, DHL made headlines
for doubling its cargo bike fleet
in Miami from four bikes...
to eight.
New York City's cargo bike pilot
featured just 350 bikes spread out
among all these companies.
So what's keeping them from going all in?
This map of Paris can help us understand why.
The city has specific rules about
what kind of vehicles can drive within this area.
Delivery trucks are vans made before 2011
are only allowed within
the zone on weekends
and after 8 PM on weekdays.
Those who break the rules
are slapped with a fine.
By 2030, no diesel or gas powered vehicles
will be allowed in the zone.
These low emission zones are all over Europe.
Brussels. Lisbon.
London. Amsterdam.
Berlin. Vienna. Rome.
Oslo. Prague. Budapest.
So for a freight operator
doing business in Europe
it makes sense to make the switch
from vans to cargo bikes...
especially since a lot of these cities also offer
generous subsidies to businesses
making the switch.
And they've invested millions
in infrastructure
like protected bike lanes to help
keep cyclists safe.
As of fall 2023
the only zero-emission zone
in the United States
was a pilot project in Santa Monica
that actually ended in 2022.
It was one square mile and
it was voluntary.
As in, no fines for trucks
that broke the rules.
There's also the fact that interstate highways
run right through a lot of
American cities...
unlike in Europe.
And for freight companies looking
to move goods quickly...
vans on the highway seems like
the obvious answer.
Of course, switching those vans
from gas to electric
would definitely help reduce CO2 emissions.
But electric trucks and vans aren't any safer
for the pedestrians and cyclists
trying to share the road.
Between 2010 and 2021...
pedestrian deaths in the US rose 54%.
Among cyclists: 55%.
And experts blame a deadly combination
of high speeds
and bigger vehicles...
which are more likely to cause fatal
head and neck injuries.
Without big changes like
urban highway removals
zero emission zones and subsidies
US cities will have a hard time
getting companies to make the switch.
And we will miss out
on the possibility of cleaner air...
safer streets and a more livable planet.